that was a mistake forget everything you
think you know about marvel marvel
movies and tv shows are
some of the most popular and beloved
blockbusters in the world
with countless films and shows there's
plenty of marvelous scenes featuring
your favorite heroes and villains
that never made their way to the final
cut
here are the marvel scenes that didn't
make the final product
you want to think about removing
yourself from this environment doctor i
was in calcutta i was pretty well
removed
spoilers ahead for black widow the
film's end credit scene with
elena whistling at natasha's tombstone
after endgame
almost ended in a completely different
way instead of valentina making a cameo
as a teaser to hawkeye
director kate shortland revealed that
originally there were plans for a
whistle response
hinting that our beloved natasha may
still be alive
it could be fun though a deleted scene
in captain
america civil war expanded upon
natasha's real family in a scene
set after peggy's funeral with natasha
opening up to steve
natasha confesses to steve that i went
back to russia and tried to find my
parents
two little gravestones by a chain-link
fence
revealing her father's name was ivan the
frog version of thor
known as throgg makes a quick cameo in
the fifth episode of loki but he almost
showed up even earlier in the series in
a slightly larger role
writer for loki eric martin revealed on
twitter that a scene was shot for the
time theater sequence in episode 1
that had throgg taking down loki this is
a mistake i shouldn't be
here in an alternate version of this
vital scene in end game
instead of natasha wrestling with
hawkeye over who will be sacrificed for
the soul stone
initially thanos and his army were
supposed to arrive on vormir
setting up a big action sequence that
ends with clint and natasha racing to
the edge of the cliff
leading to natasha's ultimate fate a
deleted scene from end game set during
tony's demise showed every avenger on
the battlefield taking a knee to honor
the fallen hero
as pepper peter and rhodey stand by his
side while this scene definitely carries
some weight
one could argue that tony's funeral
scene also has the exact same impact
part of the journey is the end
behind-the-scenes shots of black widow
reveal that the prison break scene was
almost
even more chaotic during the sequence
there was originally going to be a
prison riot
with other inmates getting involved in
the end director kate shortland and her
crew decided to shorten the scene and
make it
much more direct
a deleted sequence from one division
featuring monica
darcy and ralph was planned showing them
breaking into agatha's basement to
rescue billy and
tommy and encounter agatha's pet rabbit
senor scratchy
during a podcast director matt shakman
revealed they reach over to pet him and
then this whole
american werewolf in london
transformation happens and the rabbit
turns into this big
demon and then this whole goonies set
piece ensues where they try to escape
from the rabbit
nice tricks i liked yours too
a hilarious deleted scene and end game
had rocket questioning the avengers on
just how long their battle with the
shitari took
when natasha tells him two or three
hours rocket scoffs and says that
chatari are one of the suckiest armies
in the galaxy
and they could have just blown up their
mothership the aftermath is
even better we didn't know that was a
thing
you didn't know that was a thing talk
about embarrassing
a deleted scene revealed that bruce
banner and his green half almost came to
a truce much earlier than the events of
endgame
in the scene banner hawks out and
emerges from the hulkbuster armor and
confronts natasha and falcon
as natasha prepares to calm hulk down
with her lullaby the big green guy
reveals that his two halves
worked it out it feels very very
manageable
i hear it too another scene set during
tony's sacrifice featured tony
encountering a familiar face
after snapping his fingers with the iron
gauntlet tony finds himself in the soul
realm where he confronts a teenaged
version of his daughter
played by katherine langford where she
thanks him for his sacrifice
i love you three thousand we love you
3002
tony one hilarious deleted scene from
thor ragnarok
shows thor stumbling upon a holographic
video of the grand master
dancing around with tentacles as he's
watching bruce walks in
and starts to eat before realizing what
exactly is on the video
awkward trying to focus a deleted scene
from captain america the winter soldier
occurs with natasha talking to nick fury
after recently learning that he's still
alive
natasha asks fury why he never told her
he was still alive
he explains to her that i had to keep
the circle small
and tells her she would have done the
same thing i know
that's a problem end game almost
featured a bigger
and heartbreaking tease leading up to
the events of wandavision
the deleted scene in question would have
taken place in the film's conclusion and
had wanda
opening up a body bag to find vision's
corpse
before it was taken apart during the
events of wandavision
i can't feel you a deleted scene from
ant-man features the villainous darren
cross assembling a bidding war for the
shrink tech
with one of the bitters having a
familiar looking tattoo on his neck
the tattoo is the emblem for the
nefarious ten rings organization
whose origins trace back from iron man
and iron man 3 as well as playing a role
in chongqi
a cut scene that would have played near
the beginning of black panther opens
with a young t'challa
and nakia being caught playing in the
catacombs by t'chaka tachaka then has a
talk with t'challa
about a tough decision he had made just
hours earlier
hinting at the fate of killmonger's
father young t'challa replies by saying
you told me that every choice a king
makes
is difficult while this scene may feel
insignificant at first it does
strengthen the relationship between
t'challa and his late father
a major theme throughout the film i am
not
ready to be without you a deleted scene
from the avengers centered around a
family
attempting to drive away from the
chittari chaos
only to be pursued by one of the
soldiers captain america swoops in
and rescues the family with the scene
ending with the sun handing cap his
shield
this scene only builds upon the good
nature of steve rogers and how he always
manages to look out for everyone
co-writer rhett reese revealed that a
potential post-credit scene for deadpool
2
would have entailed new interviews for
the x-force with chris evans showing up
as a potential team member
instead of deadpool calling out evans as
cap he would have pointed evans out as
the human torch
first day so nervous
this deleted scene would have amped up
the 80s flavor of apocalypse featuring
cyclops
jean grey jubilee and nightcrawler
visiting a mall
while some of the sequence made it into
the final product there were several
character moments that were left on the
cutting room floor
nightcrawler in particular had several
moments cut out
including his excitement that the humans
at the mall don't fear his appearance
sword recently made its mcu debut in
wandavision
however it almost made its debut earlier
an alternate ending for the first thor
film features
dr selvig mention the organization while
instructing a team of scientists
in an attempt to build a portal to find
thor we cross-reference them
with a sword database this can't be seen
from the first fantastic four film
almost included a brief mention of
another famous marvel team
the x-men while sharing a romantic
moment with sue
reed morphs his face to resemble the
famous clawed hero wolverine whether
this meant that the fantastic four
and the x-men co-existed in fox's marvel
universe
remains to be seen but just imagine the
possibilities
you're done good kid
come on these deleted scenes were likely
left on the cutting room floor for a
reason
but one has to wonder if some of these
may have brought an extra flavor to
marvel movies
from big action set pieces to small
character moments the makers behind the
marvel movies
probably have all kinds of deleted
goodies what's your favorite deleted
scene